[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever we want so
why are you wearing a robe I'm wearing a
robe because I was in Las Vegas this
weekend and and you boxed and I hey hey
boxed Floyd Mayweather's a son he's 10
years old and I lost no Bobby lose too
but I still won yeah because I sued him
afterwards yeah not I I bought this from
Caesars Palace I saw a robe in the gift
shop and it's a kid's robe because the
real roads like you know ok ok
so the real roads you know will go like
all the way all the way down right but
this is like a kid's Road so I can wear
it like like it's fitted like a shirt
jacket looks good it looks good I want I
thought of on Chi I want a roll it's
Versace no no these are watching so
Sachi is this Cesar watch E and it comes
I also bought a little matching like
thing that like wraps around like a
little like like a little toga oh yeah
but the robes are meant to be worn naked
yeah underneath your ties they make it
no I'm just saying that's the real way
it's the comfortable way and it comes up
there come on you opposed it bro it's
like a karate belt to everyone look oh
but you know it's a little kids inside
do you like the gamble ID I used to I
used to but not anymore
because I never like really one enough
to make me feel like yeah I'm gonna keep
doing it what's the most you want on a
couple hundred bucks oh you're not
playing good enough
with all the [ __ ] money you make I'm
ashamed of you how can you be Asian
don't you do this [ __ ] for Thai New Year
no no I don't cuz the thing about it is
I started being like man lemme just
instead of like trying to win money I
was like let me just use this [ __ ] on
[ __ ] I know I'm like let me just buy
some shoes or no no that's not the point
the point the point is the thrill of
losing enough money that's gonna make
you sweat you are not a real agent
unless you gamble I guess not
cuz you want to have the feeling of
regret where you're like [ __ ] I could've
bought 10 pairs of shoes but guess what
I lost that [ __ ] dinner like I gamble
I'd rather spend that money at like the
strip club you know you are too
responsible
oh my guarantees man what's wrong with
you generates I'm gonna degenerate only
Envy a mother I'm a thrill seeker
yeah it's the thrill it's like that it's
like that like the feeling of things not
being able to go your way right that's
life though like that whole life isn't
but now it's a concentrated version
every single second about to lose your
life savings it's like oh [ __ ]
it's like skydiving it feels great mean
you know what it even scared what
skydive I would now you would know I
told you like I'm scared I'm a [ __ ]
I'll do it I'll do it if you guys want
me to do it I'll do it he'll do it
reluctantly yeah I don't like he'll
challenge himself and do it but he won't
enjoy there's a ton of [ __ ] that I'll do
that [ __ ] hey bow do it it's got
nothing fun bro I know if I'm scared man
it's like especially since like you go
with like you you're if it's your first
time you're strapped to a professional
and [ __ ] so it's like you don't really
feel like that's what I'm scared of
because those fools they can smell that
you're scared oh this fool behind me or
he's right like this fall he's a little
[ __ ] and he's like I'm gonna jump out
the plan and do one of those flips I
think I can because they could smell it
like I was so jealous of Casey he got to
do all the crazy flips I'm like damn
lucky am i boring you because he
probably smelled this fear and you apart
there a thirsty ass
and so he was probably like hell no I'm
flipping your ass [ __ ] Thursday yeah
he's like yeah you're gonna get [ __ ]
juices all over my my jumpsuit
her vagina Jesus oh yeah she was all
horny from the jump is what I'm saying
oh I never thought about that part
oh yeah my bachelor party Vegas it was
fun it was fun um but you know I was
just thinking to like turn my gambling
like yeah I realized I didn't get into
gambling because I used to do it when I
didn't really have money so now I feel
like maybe I should do it again now that
I kind of have some money yeah money
when I didn't have money it was like
every time I lost money I was like
that's lunch
that's some real [ __ ] you know right and
when I win I'm like holding my hundred
dollars like I'm gonna play anymore yeah
my 21st birthday my friends got me a
hotel room all that stuff I didn't have
to pay for [ __ ] they gave me money to
gamble all that stuff when I [ __ ] won
money the first day I just held it and
they're like why don't you keep playing
I'm like no you gave me 100 bucks you
can have him back but I'm gonna keep the
winnings yeah he's like nah man keep
playing with those like that's how you
lose in life buddy
you know I like about gambling it's it's
like once in a while you get to
disrespect money it's like you have the
lady right and he treated like a queen
mm-hmm but every once in a while when
you have sex just want to slap her in
the [ __ ] face and the calling a
little [ __ ] and chakra on your dad to
Juliet you know anything yet he's
waiting for the right moment when I was
born the last time I Vegas were playing
craps right and when you're and regular
life and you think about how much things
cost like 100 bucks is a lot right now
you can buy a whole meal you could buy
it's like food for like a couple days
but when you're playing and then I
started playing I was gambling 20 bucks
then I was 50 bucks a hand then a
hundred and then it was like 300 bucks
and then 500 bucks and so once it gets
to that point on my [ __ ] you 500 because
then now I'm not looking at it in real
life
mm-hmm I'm looking at as like
I'm [ __ ] slap your round you don't
control me [ __ ] okay and then uh you
win and you lose something and you
thought I was crazy
Nami I get it I get it all right this
guy's quite as [ __ ] but we win the craps
table copies he's the star of the show
man all of us are taking it back like
damn look at this [ __ ] loud ass over
here
[ __ ] yeah I'm like damn for never seen
so much energy it feels like he saves it
up to like that yeah I really do and in
all of it just comes out I really do
I don't even drink by drinking Vegas dad
oh really all right let's go let's go
back y'all were fun to [ __ ] play with
man let's go there that's the party
number two that's a party number two a
little go for the next year the next
year I'm trying to save money and be
responsible in the money right now
okay look after we both get divorced
yeah we'll go on a double bachelor party
huh a double divorce party we all get
the board a triple the board why don't
y'all go and get an Elvis divorce at
Vegas do your thing he doesn't come back
and then get like a [ __ ] I don't know
like a Bruce Lee marriage that's some
new [ __ ] they should have a Bruce Lee
marriage disavow and then renew the vows
and have David Lee Bruce Lee since he's
all like kickboxer boy now yes doing
like a Cantonese accent to promise
anything you get so do it at Tim's
wedding it hasn't happened yet yeah true
true are you down who's doing your
official Shirish I know but who this
with that game who's gonna appreciate
him
lucky few guys who do you guys think
write in the copy you can kick you guess
it I'll tell you Nick Cannon do we know
you do what's a surprise right it's a
surprise Floyd Mayweather that wasn't it
now wasn't it Ricky shock no way he I
we're not friends anymore your dad I'm
gone no I'm not my dad
Britney shucks is actually uh well Rick
and and superego and PD flow they're my
best men's I didn't like a baby your
website is so funny she has like a
paragraph for each of the people in her
went in her bridal party but in you it's
just like my dude when you have a real
relationship with somebody do not
explain on that [ __ ] and I just
thought it'd be funny hers is like
Mellie my cousin my sweets have known
you for so long of course you had to be
like part of my special day and I'm like
Rick my dude period speak so much you
know my dude how'd you spell it do OD
not just do you do the original way yeah
the og way I've been using do od'd a lot
have you yeah cuz it feels different
ones like my dude and they look like my
do you know what I go with sometimes let
the de WD do next or I'll be like babe
I'm pooping PE WP I like that one too I
like that one
what's the difference between pooping
and pooping to you is it a different
mode poop like pooping is like like I'm
really like into this right like I'm
pooping pooping feels spin I'm just
tubing I get this small erotic a 10 inch
puke you know there are just poops and
pubes Oh have you guys seen that Vanessa
Carlton hood remake no well it's like
pew pew pew pew yes my salad
not actually like five times over and
over again oh yeah is it a song or is it
a music video it's a music video
Oh making my way through the hood
sipping this yeah
[Music]
yo that's funny I love the internet
there's really pew pew pew and reminded
me that song I love it it's so cool so
yeah my best part was fun
did she have a bachelorette party she
was gonna um cuz she was gonna go to
like Vancouver with a couple of
homegirls cuz her home girls are getting
married - yeah and then like I think it
was just like it was a whole lot going
on so she was like nevermind I got [ __ ]
to do ya know but she said I think when
all her girls are here for the actual
for our wedding yeah cuz they'll be here
like a week before they might do like
you know spa day
club day whatever strip club day you
know what if she gets a bunch of
prostitutes I told her I told her like
yo if you go to the strip club like the
guy strip club I want her to have the
best experience like I want her to have
fun you know so like if there's a Jake
like in your face like you can grab it
but I told her like just don't stroke it
because then I feel like then it's an
act you feel me then it's like a sexual
act but if the date I think you're gonna
be like have fun
like the most experience like yeah if
there's a dick around like oh [ __ ] it I
mean I thought that's what you were
gonna say I thought you were open-minded
no I mean I was having eyes I said she
can she can grab it
I mean look here's the thing she if she
wants to [ __ ] some stripper dick I would
never find out so you know babe have fun
you know do you think would that make
you jealous
if she stroked a [ __ ] stripper dick
if she stroked a stripper dick I might
you know
oh no I fight a fab you jealous I feel
like I feel a little way about it though
like cuz it's messy since I'm like hey
man just grab it don't stroke it cuz
there's like uh you're stroking it's
because like you know you're trying to
like she's not get anything out of that
well maybe she doesn't she's like
stroking Bigfoot well that's kind of
like grabbing boobie yeah it's like it's
like there's there's feet and then
there's oh yeah yeah the boobie doesn't
react though if you stroke the dick is
called a boobie doesn't go through hard
hmm
yeah but doesn't grow in size it doesn't
go being will come back at you if you
stroke it he's like Oh
I would
how come how come girls don't do that or
is it a mystery like you know how guys
like bachelor party it seems so [ __ ]
like outrageous and destructive and then
girls the the bachelorette party don't
seem that destructive boys will be boys
and like it's just that like gym locker
right so what are girls doing these days
I feel like babe they have spa days and
they go to the club and maybe they'll
maybe they'll grind on a boy they'd do
the same [ __ ] guys do now a lot of
prostitutes is that what guys do that's
are supposed to I'm not gonna live - the
last time the Bangor hookers as a
bachelor party what one time I was in
Vegas and this was during my like my
Coopie stage we're all just kind of
having fun and I didn't care you know
and I ran into this girl at a club in
Vegas and she was like she knew who I
was you know and then we went back to
her room and like smashed and stuff and
she's like well yeah he's just like I'm
I'm engaged and she's like this is like
my last like low weekend you know well
she might told me before I don't wish it
on Bush she's like I'm engaged thank you
for being my Christmas present okay look
to be honest when I was when I was just
doing my thing I was out there like I
wouldn't have cared you know if she's
like yeah I'm engaged is my last weekend
to do my thing so like we smashed were
you like congratulations yeah wins the
ceremony's pictures wow wow she was like
I joined do you want to get my number
and she said no oh [ __ ] cool I was like
that's the first time I really felt like
wow she just used me for my date and
that was it and it was cottage I was
totally cool with it I was like wow
awesome you didn't get hurt like hey I'm
supposed to do that no cuz it was what
it was you know how much you wanted a
dick she use me for my dick and now is
issues and they want to talk to me again
I was like damn yeah I'm so curious man
it's like because I also feel like girls
are very secretive I feel like on the
surface Diggle we're gonna have a spa
day but then like it's like a [ __ ]
Chinese restaurant with a casino on the
back right right go through the spa get
all these naked dudes with [ __ ] vinyl
faces in the [ __ ] bar gagging [ __ ]
all that stuff going on at the spa at
the spa
how did he know huh girls what's really
going on we got to stop they know really
going on Code Red Code Red is there is
there like a thing that girls do like
one thing before we [ __ ] cuz you know
how like guys like we gotta go to the
strip club we got we can't do this [ __ ]
we're married and then they still do
anyway but then like a girl thing where
it's like man we got to [ __ ] do
something we got to do this thing I
don't know
I guess like Vegas is always a thing
right yeah you always see them going we
gotta go [ __ ] crazy go see the
Chippendale good girl person cuz you
know if I'm gonna start a diet I'm like
that like if I'm gonna start a diet on
Monday you got Sunday it's Pizza
McDonald's like yeah so it's just like
anytime about to get into something I
feel like it's guy behavior to be I'm
gonna be destructive like crazy the day
before is that even part of girl person
I do know I think the trope is just you
hang out with your girls and then the
most you'll probably do is like flirt or
dance with a dude but then it's just
mainly like just like doing drugs or
just [ __ ] around and just dancing or
going out I mean I feel like I've heard
I've heard stories of girls like but I
mean I just told you a story of a girl
the [ __ ] before you know so it's like
maybe something some of them do I'm sure
they do
well like I guess I'm going based off of
like what movies put in there and I
think you should get like your friends
experience or like leading you yeah yeah
yeah yeah like that's it really chill
yeah like he's really chill no I've
never hung out with the girl that was
like about to get married I got as many
dudes as I can cuz you know like that's
not really ugly I never had that feeling
of like oh if I get married man I gotta
have one last thing like I gotta go and
have a [ __ ] coupe sex session yeah
you know I gotta get my ass seen by as
many girls as possible it's 20 I need a
[ __ ] line up ten women bent over a
[ __ ] go one pumper each and she do
all kinds of don't ask I don't [ __ ]
think that dude I'm like well if I
wanted to do that if I had that desire
why am I even thinking of marriage I
mean even if my bachelor party is like I
wasn't even I wasn't feeling that either
you know like yeah but mr. stripped
leather strip was fun you know it's like
yeah naked girl dance cool but it's like
I have more fun buying lap dances for
people than getting one my
I love that [ __ ] right I love watching
people get embarrassed and [ __ ] I'll be
like Oh someone get three girls and put
it on you watch a bashful ask it already
dude Pat yeah that wasn't passed kids
getting my [ __ ] yeah and you bought
me one I'm like you don't even give me a
hot one but I'll take one anyway think I
can't see them if they're on me you
don't mean like you can't see the girl
so it's when they're ordinary that's why
I do this you do this you got my face
can you imagine a lap dance look at me
baby look at mom yeah Eskimo kiss the
whole time during the lap dance
no I feel like um so my thing is back
then I feel like yeah that would have
turned me on a lot right but now just
having female bodies on me isn't enough
I feel you because I mean like what do
you need I need connection I'm a grown
man yeah it's either connection or I
need to see that [ __ ]
so then watching her in a distance I see
her whole body and then I see that
moving and [ __ ] I get that that's hotter
to me then then that on me because we're
not connecting she doesn't like me she
doesn't want me so it's like her rubbing
my skin and [ __ ] it's like I rather go
home and jackoff I know how to do it way
better yeah that's true I rather watch
the performance of course that's way
better because the sex is just way
better when you take the time with your
person you know like they know they
[ __ ] make you bust like that mm-hmm
oh yeah dude it's like a curse when you
first [ __ ] me a girl and you have sex
with her you can last like a [ __ ]
champion and then she learns all your
[ __ ] yeah and then you go inside
you're like damn you do all the [ __ ]
high-level [ __ ] real fast what the [ __ ]
no I definitely bus a fast one girl the
first time yeah this is him it's like in
my day there was times walls like yo I
[ __ ] laid it down I get he's got some
good ass dick right now right and the
other times I was like [ __ ] she's gonna
go tell all her friends that I got
wagging dick because I busted mad fast
like it's like it's been either/or for
me like I either like put it down
champ or I've been like Daniel you know
what you know I'm sorry I don't know
what happens not like yeah it's like
[ __ ] man especially super fast like bug
you gotta be like yo I don't know what
happened like I'm you don't have to say
that you just have to be like damn you
were so hot I couldn't know there's that
too
my bad know the facts looks like no you
know you were too tight I wasn't used to
that but guess that's it's true like
even though it sounds like something
people would just say it's true those
like you know you were to say I'm sorry
you know wow that's Talent
hell yeah that's [ __ ] Talent
[Music]